as time moves forward the currency of
entertainment changes
when the primary form of entertainment
was movies it was ticket sales when it
became TV it was about fewer numbers
these days in the age of streaming
it's become about engagement
and I'm starting to think that might be
a problem
[Music]
hey folks so I want to talk about the
broad topic and the idea of how building
a show for engagement can impact the way
in which the final product actually
takes shape and I'm going to springboard
this off of a specific piece of work
that that time of recording is still
airing now this isn't going to be
strictly about the show and or the Star
Wars spin-off show that is currently on
Disney plus but I want to start there
because that's what got me thinking
about this so there were a couple of
pieces that I saw that came out around
the same time talking about Andor and
sort of talking about how while not an
outright flop
buy the Disney plus standards it wasn't
doing so hot now there's a couple of
different metrics that sort of come into
this first there's the Nielsen ratings
now people are probably aware at this
point that streaming services actually
don't have to share their actual viewing
numbers they're not required to the way
someone broadcasting over systems and
onto TV sets actually has to do so while
Nielsen does not have a complete picture
of all streaming numbers it can't unless
that information is volunteered by the
streaming platform and it almost never
is
they are still able to track what number
of people streamed it to a TV set
um or at least in the terms of how they
tend to measure these things these days
is how many minutes was this watched in
total as opposed to number of people
watch because you know do you count it
as a view if somebody turn something on
and only watch it for five minutes half
of the show does it have to be three
quarters it's easier to qual to qualify
it by number of minutes watched and
that's what Nielsen currently does so
for comparison andor's minutes watched
First Premiere came in behind Obi-Wan
Kenobi but ahead of the book of Boba
Fett depending on how you read the data
and this is another case where it gets a
little bit weird I don't want to linger
on this too long because I have other
places I want this conversation to go
but this is worth acknowledging so by
raw number of total minutes watched and
or did beat the book of Boba Fett
however the book of Boba Fett premiered
with one episode and or premiered with
three now if you assume a simple math
equation of okay well then divide Anders
number by 3 that tells you the per
minutes watching gives you a better idea
of how comparisonable buffet and if
you're doing that then it comes in
behind Boba Fett but it's unclear
whether or not that's an accurate
measure either because while we know a
total number of minutes across three
episodes we don't know how many people
only watch one episode save the others
for later is it a smaller number of
total viewers watching all three
episodes in one go or is it a higher
number of viewers not binging all three
at once we don't really know and even if
it is a case of fewer total viewers
binging all three at once that's still
arguably a very good sign because that's
showing a high commitment rate from
those viewers who are willing to sink in
the full three episodes whereas the
people watching the premiere of Boba
Fett only had to commit to one so
there's still something debatable there
but it is not performing amazingly and
depending on how you measure it either
coming in a bit ahead of Boba Fett or
behind it but there's a whole other set
of metrics and that has to do with its
engagement now most of the data that I
looked at for this comes from a company
called parrot analytics and what parrot
analytics does is again because it does
not have access to the actual streaming
numbers what it instead monitors is how
much is this being talked about so it's
scraping data from Facebook Twitter
various social media YouTube videos what
the viewership on those is like all
these other factors to figure out how
much are people talking about this
compared to your average show now going
against the normal average for shows on
the day that the Andor premiered
happened it was doing pretty well about
six times above the average
the thing is though that's really low by
Disney plus standards Obi-Wan Kenobi the
book of Boba Fett and the Mandalorian
all enjoyed from the range of 25 to 30
times the average for the first seasons
and the mandalorian's second season
premiere was 60 times the average this
is not even coming close so what this
General picture would seem to paint is
that Andor is doing okay by numbers a
little bit down possibly now that is the
numbers at the time of the premiere
Andor has actually picked up a little
bit more well actually initially it
dipped and then it picked up more after
that but that's sort of an over the time
tracking which isn't really one I want
to focus on right now what I want to
talk about it here is the way that this
measure of Engagement
doesn't really line up with even the
least generous interpretation of the
Nielsen data because yes if you want to
be as harsh as possible that does show
Endor coming in below the others but not
by that much
so what's going on here
I think this actually has a lot to do
with just the way that Andor is built as
a show
by way of illustration and somewhat
anecdotally I have been doing Episode by
episode reviews of Endor over on my
secondary Channel break room of Geeks
which is where most of my review
material goes if it's not uh new
episodes of Doctor Who pretty much all
of it goes there but the thing is that
I've actually been finding it difficult
with each subsequent episode to find
much to talk about
because it's not a show built around
massive reveals big twists huge set
pieces you know real wow I gotta talk
about that moments
it's on a slow burn it's telling a
continuous story it is paced for the
Long Haul and as a result
each episode comes out I find myself
going well
the stuff that was good about all the
episodes I talked prior to this
yeah all that's still good like some new
stuff happened but it's all the same
strengths and I have actually pointed
out in some of the more recent reviews
I'm struggling to think of specific
things to say other than just recount
the plot of the new episode which is not
how I like to structure reviews
and that seems to match up with the fact
that people just aren't talking about as
much it's not designed to be a water
cooler show it's not designed on an
episode by episode basis to make people
go whoa what did everyone think of that
let me get on to social media and find
out it's just not built that way
and it's a massive exception
for that fact especially on Disney plus
because Disney plus has been building
its things around big moments impactful
things things that make you want to
respond whether it be positively or
negatively everything from the
incredibly bizarre out of left field
start to WAND division to later things
that went on there with things like the
casting of Evan Peters as a fake Pietro
and then with things like Falcon and the
Winter Soldier the integration of
characters like Zemo or the fact that
somebody literally got killed with cap
Shield like these are Big wow I either
need to talk about that or I need to see
what other people think about that
moment and there was similar stuff in
all the other Star Wars shows I mean the
Mandalorian the big thing was grogu AKA
baby Yoda really blew the dang thing up
but even after that the use of existing
characters especially in the second
season those became major talking points
that spurred That season onto very high
engagement book of Boba Fett had the
initial appeal of a character from the
movies but then integrating various
things from other shows including two
episodes that basically served as just
extensions of the Mandalorian which
whether you thought those episodes were
good or not I actually couldn't stand
them but that was something to talk
about because that's the other thing
about engagement
engagement doesn't care
if you liked it or if you hated it it
only cares that you're talking about it
that is why trying to figure out how
many people online hate a thing
is not really a measure of it failing
like the
intended fan base has to basically fully
Revolt for that kind of thing to really
upend things and that can happen and
does on occasion but like if a bunch of
people just don't like a thing or going
oh this was dumb that doesn't
necessarily mean it's unsuccessful
because if people are talking about it
maybe you'd prefer they talk about it uh
positively
but if they're talking about it and
they're coming back to watch it again
the minutes clocked from a hate watch
are no less valuable than the minutes
clock from someone who loves every
single second of it
and the words spent talking about how
great the thing is
drives engagement just as much possibly
even less than people who talk about how
much they can't stand it because the
thing is
arguments actually tend to spur on a lot
more conversation now engagement is by
no means the only measure of success and
we've seen plenty of instances over the
past few years where something becomes
highly talked about but that does not
mean it's successful but the fact that
so much emphasis put on engagement is
part of what led to things like the fact
that Sony re-released morbius into the
theater
because it had high engagement it had
high engage because it was memed to
death
people tore it apart the whole morbin
time thing took off and people yes they
were talking about the movie but they
were making fun of it nobody it wasn't
even that people didn't like it they
actually didn't even see it they just
thought it was fun to make fun of but
because that engagement ranked so high
Sony thought oh
we'll put it back in the theater we'll
go and see it no
no they didn't
so right there is sort of the most
extreme recent example of Engagement
driving a bad decision
but to bring it back to Disney because I
feel like this is the one I kind of have
the best view of overall and how this
can impact things
you can see how something like Wanda
Vision on a per episode basis after its
initial debut of the first three
episodes that sort of shows the jump in
sitcom Styles but then any given episode
giving a big people are going to want to
talk about this moment whether it be
Monica Rambo whether it be Pietro
whether it be Agatha
[Music]
something big happens and drives the
engagement but and or
just isn't built like that
it's built to tell a story over chunk of
time
and not to have specific pops per
episode to get a certain amount of oh
moments per episode it's just not
designed to do that and it's really good
and it's actually being very well
reviewed I don't like to bring a rotten
tomatoes on here for a Litany of reasons
but just for a comparison by the end of
its run and or outperform the
Mandalorian with critics though not with
audiences and it came in ahead of both
the book of Boba Fett and Obi-Wan Kenobi
with both audiences and critics so it's
not like people don't like it
they just aren't talking about it
and that does not lessen its value as a
piece of art I actually think it's the
best thing that Star Wars has done in
years
but we're at the risk of it being seen
as a failure
because of this lack of Engagement I'm
just incredibly grateful that it was
already set up to have two seasons and
that they're already making the second
one and that's where it's intended to
stop because if this was a show that's
future was going to depend on the
reaction to the first season we probably
wouldn't get more of this all right or
we'd get a very shortened season or
something
because the way stuff's being measured
now
just isn't what it was before
and while this does impact movies like I
said morbius that's a following your
face example this has a very clear
impact I think on shows that are either
made specifically for streaming or that
know they're going to have a high
percentage of Their audience on
streaming because you can even look at
something like House of the Dragon which
does just air on HBO but also shows up
on HBO Max and is how a lot of people
watch it most episodes have a big moment
whether it be
a shocking death a Twist reveal whether
it be this uncovering of you know some
characters intentions or just a moment
that kind of makes you go
there's something there to drive the
engagement because if you're not being
talked about you don't get measured as
being as valuable and even something
like She-Hulk which isn't structured the
way most of Disney plus stuff is
structured
still seem to have a lot of those
moments with its guest appearances from
characters like Wong or its appearances
by the Abomination or with Daredevil and
some of these actually worked quite well
but
there does still feel like a little bit
of a cynical Edge to it we're putting
these in for the extra pop for the extra
engagement now
a show that is well done can still take
moments like that and make them not feel
forced have them feel like an actual
part of the story and strike that
balance
but if you're aiming first and foremost
to create a piece of engaging media
and that is your higher concern than
whether or not as a piece of good
storytelling
that's always going to be something that
concerns me a bit
but of course this is just kind of the
nature of the entertainment industry
which is that there is that constant
struggle between what artists want to
create and what the people whose money
is funding these projects need them to
return
and as I said that has always been there
there has always been tension between
the people who want to make a piece of
art the way they think it'll best
represent what they want it to be and
the people who need that thing to make
its money back and then some because
they expect a return on investment and
those needs can often and do often Clash
as much as I enjoy the MCU the vast
majority of it at least when these
properties try and Tackle bigger ideas
they're not completely bad at I
personally don't think but not with a
lot of teeth not with a lot of Gusto
because well
it needs Mass Market appeal
to drive the numbers
the tickets the engagement and Marvel
especially at this point engages like
almost nothing else does because of the
interconnected nature of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
you can drop something that hints at
things that aren't even confirmed yet
you can hint at a character you can have
someone show up who we haven't seen in
several movies you can do any number of
things and suddenly that's going to
drive up engagement massively because
it's such a talked about an
interconnected thing that it could
theoretically mean any number of things
engagement is especially the lifeblood
of Marvel it has created a cottage
industry of people who not only are
watching all the things whether they
love it or hate it who are not only
watching and talk about each individual
things but they're talking about the
casting they're doing overviews about
the comics origins of these characters
before they hit the big screen they're
doing speculation videos about what
future stories might be or how certain
characters might be used all of this is
a monstrous machine of Engagement and
while Star Wars isn't quite at that
level it's not too too far behind and DC
is definitely trying to get there we'll
see what James Gunn at the helm of that
thing creatively is able to do with it
but they've obviously wanted that as
well but haven't been able to attain it
because well
things uh haven't actually fit together
particularly clearly right now but in
the age of Engagement driving things
Marvel has
undeniably
mastered that and don't get me wrong I
still like Marvel overall and most of
its individual components are still
fairly entertaining for me
but there used to be an organic kind of
Engagement that came out just the nature
of the interconnected universe and I'd
be lying if I didn't say it's starting
to feel
more mechanical
more forced the post-credits scenes feel
more token the cameos feel more for the
sake of interconnecting things where
maybe that doesn't even really need to
happen for this particular story
it's part of why something like werewolf
By Night actually felt like a bit of a
breath of fresh air it didn't need all
the connections it was able to be its
own thing still exist in that Universe
sure and I'm sure of various characters
we see there will show up in other
things but
it felt fresh compared to a lot of what
Marvel has been lately because it got to
just be and thankfully so does Andor
but
that seems to be an increasingly small
percentage of the output that's coming
out of these big engagement machines
even looking at franchises that are not
as currently dominant as Star Wars and
the MCU you can still kind of see the
impacts of that you can look at
something like Star Trek which has been
tossing out new shows almost endlessly
for several years now Picard strange new
worlds Discovery lower decks Prodigy it
seems like a lot like that's a lot of
Star Trek
but engagement is highest when there's a
new thing to talk about and while Star
Trek may not currently have the same
level of penetration and the same size
audience as your Star Wars or your
Marvel
it has a very engaged audience those who
watch it want to talk about it and if
you keep giving them something new to
talk about they will keep doing that
and Marvel is starting to feel that way
too because we've gotten a lot of stuff
and the first few Disney Plus shows felt
special because they were new I had
issues with one division even at the
time I was a bit more praising of the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier But as
time has gone on the flaws and it become
a bit more evident to me and as we move
forward it just feels like there's more
and more and more more movies per year
that themselves now start to feel a
little bit less special because we don't
have time without Marvel between the
movies we now have shows between the
movies
and so now we are no longer afforded
breathing space we are no longer
afforded the time to just think about
Marvel not have to actively engage with
it at the moment or you know for those
of us who are fans afforded the
opportunity to not have to think about
Marvel
at the time of recording we're actually
in a minor low of that because
um She-Hulk attorney at law wrapped up
we had werewolf by night and black
panther doesn't come out for a few weeks
but think about that I'm measuring time
between Marvel properties in weeks there
is a sense and this is another thing
that comes up with engagement at what
point does pushing for engagement and
for that engagement to be almost
constant
when does it bring about fatigue
cause that's something that people have
well they've been talking about Marvel
for ages and just in general the idea of
superhero fatigue it might finally be
starting to settle in to whatever extent
it's going to
and I think there can certainly be
fatigue of specific franchises I love
Star Wars but I do not watch every Star
Wars thing that comes out I'm already
kind of fatigued on it and or actually
kind of lit the fire under me a little
bit for the first time in quite a while
but it took a show atypical
of what engagement machine production
makes and it's a show that's not doing
as well by engagement measures as
basically everything else made by that
machine
and it worries me that it's the
exception that I'm latching on to as the
thing that's really getting me excited
to enjoy this because
if it's not hitting those same metrics
will it be looked at as something not
worth doing again
because this is what ultimately always
happens over time eventually as the ones
who write the checks want to break down
component parts of the things that are
making the most money or driving the
most engagement and try and figure out
what is replicable what can we do again
what isn't doing as well
and Things become
homogenized and again to be clear Andor
is not a failure but it shows a decline
level of initial interest compared
to the other streamy shows particularly
the Star Wars ones
now
the biggest threat often is when the
bean counters the number crunchers and
the people who write the checks think
they have figured it out
and it helps when they get reminded no
maybe there's stuff you're not
accounting for yet and actually it helps
people like me for that to happen too
because I don't want to sound like I
know everything because I don't but to
take an example of something that really
caught a lot of folks off guard
the Lord of the Rings show on Amazon
Prime its numbers were pretty good but
for how expensive it was to make
people were prepared to label it not a
total failure but a failure versus what
it cost to put up not worth it
but you know what happened
that almost nobody predicted those
numbers shot up once the season was done
because it was coming out week to week
not as a binge format the way Netflix
does but once people were able to binge
it from start to finish its numbers shot
up hugely
it was a show that people wanted to see
but were waiting until it was done
and how often that happens
is unfortunately Again difficult to
track
because of how much information we are
able to get from streaming platforms
but that's something a lot of people
didn't count on
a lot of people have expressed an
exhaustion with the binging model that
Netflix kind of pioneered I've expressed
exhaustion with the binging model that
Netflix kind of pioneered but at the
same time maybe certain things just need
to be formatted differently because of
the audience they're meant for maybe the
fact that Andor is not only structured
in a way that is not meant to have
specific individual big or moments per
episode but in fact is set up in sort of
little sets of three episodes forming
little mini trilogies maybe those should
have all been released as blocks maybe
the way that they release episodes one
through three they should have also
released episodes four to six they
should have also released episodes seven
to nine maybe that would have done
better maybe with how things have
improved over time maybe it's just
turned out to have a longer tail and
took a little while to get going it's
difficult to know
but
I feel like the more that I look at what
is being produced especially for
streaming platforms like Disney plus and
I'm mainly focusing on Disney plus
because
Netflix and HBO Max are in varying
degrees of turmoil right now Netflix is
having to Pivot following some of its
losses from I think it was last year it
was either last year at the start of
this year I did a video on that whereas
HBO Max is just
wow it's ending it's going to be folded
in with Discovery plus into a new thing
so who even knows how to deal with that
anymore Disney plus is one of the more
stable at the moment so it feels like a
better metric and also a lot of what
Disney plus is doing is something other
companies wish they could do in terms of
building that level of Engagement with
that kind of expansive franchise
but if that's the metric and it's
churning out increasingly stuff built to
get us talking rather than get us
thinking rather than getting us to feel
rather than telling us a good story
that's gonna worry me about the way
things could likely drift over time
and may already have started engagement
is a tricky thing
like I said
positive engagement negative engagement
it all counts YouTube may have gotten
rid of the visibility of the dislike
numbers it still tracks them and it
still counts this is something that more
than a few YouTubers have pointed out
when you hit the dislike
on a video even before
they started not being uh visible
anymore
that was just the same as hitting a like
as far as the algorithm was concerned
people saw a video and cared enough
about it to voice their opinion
did they like it or did they hit it
doesn't matter
they engaged with it
what engagement focused production
builds what it encourages
worries me
because if we want to look at YouTube
and not that I necessarily expect
streaming platforms to run into the
exact same problems as YouTube
this is part of why there are so many
drama channels this is why some of the
biggest channels get into feuds and
that's not me saying the feuds are fake
I'm saying feuds Drive engagement it's
why so much outrage feels like it is
completely out of proportion to what the
thing actually is because if you shout
louder about it then people are more
likely to engage with you even if it is
to shout at you that you're wrong
my refusal to alter how I approach what
I do
to drive engagement more because I could
very easily
I could start doing more thumbnails
about how something is garbage all caps
about how something is the worst thing
ever I could start doing the thumbnails
that takes
stars or other YouTubers and make in
rearranges them so they're making a
really stupid face I could do all that
and I'd probably have better Channel
growth for doing it but I don't want to
I don't want to be part of the world
that that builds
and again while what's going on on
streaming platforms does not exactly map
on to YouTube's issues around engagement
it's just another example of how the
engagement economy
encourages not great stuff
but
it's how we are measuring things
and it's how things are built
what are your thoughts on any of this do
you think I'm worrying more than is
necessary I don't know that would be
nice whatever your thoughts are though
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it patreon's what pays
the bills and allows me to do this as my
living uh even if you can't help me out
that way like share and subscribe or
dislike if you really want to they all
do help one way or the other
what I really want you to remember
though
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
end of the video so I got a shout out my
top patrons Robin Moore Zubin mcfula to
rock the thing that goes doing in the
anime Oliver B Angus bjornison Melinda
Walters imudelki the oatha Boyd katoria
toyololi Becky Sparks for navilax the
poodle Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Tim price Adam r d l Taylor Jayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose
thanks for your support if you want to
hear me probably mispronounce your name
as well check out the rewards on the
patreon
what you doing there
[Music]